People instinctively
run from fire.
So, we burn them out!
And if we burn down
the palace in the process?
We'll build a new one, Orlo.
New palace, new Russia.
This-- this is madness.
These are some of the best sets
we've ever seen,
and I... it's true.
I'm not biased.
♪♪
TONY McNAMARA: This year,
we wanted the palace to change
because Catherine could change.
We wanted
the costumes to change,
because she was older
and had a stronger look.
MARIAN MACGOWAN:
All of our designers
in Season 2,
worked beautifully
in developing our world.
The visual look is like period
show with an edge to it.
And that should be reflected
in design and costumes.
Exactly!
Visually, it was spectacular
and really fun.
Look where we are.
We have built so many sets.
My passion is really to create
spaces from scratch.
I think that's what
really excites me
in the design process.
Girls, go and stand over there
and... stare at art!
TONY: In terms of wardrobe,
and hair and makeup, and set
inspiring us to how we write,
I have a very good,
strong dialogue
with those departments
all the time.
The design process
is always sort of
responding to what
the script needs.
I am doing something here
that will change the world.
We did want the look
and the feel
of the palace interiors
to feel like they are grounded
in the 17th Century,
but not a specific palace.
We were liberated by not
being historically accurate.
That allowed us to push
a design a little bit further.
This is the Russia we create.
The nursery's great 'cause
Peter sort of designed it.
Ah! What color do you think?
Not sure.
I say each wall different.
It had been Peter's nursery,
once upon a time.
Look at that fireplace.
TONY: So it has
this amazing fireplace
that is terrifying to children.
He still has that slightly
off-kilter sense of him
in that he can't
quite understand
maybe what a child
should be witness to.
I made this for Paul using parts
from real bears.
Our costumes are so extravagant
and beautiful.
What am I wearing?
Why am I wearing this?
I can't be wearing this!
It's quite difficult
to do that century
without going overboard.
With costumes, we were always
looking for opportunities
where we can sort of
do something a bit absurd.
-Velcro.
-Love it.
SHARON:
Catherine the Great
was so clever,
she used clothes as a tool.
ELLE:
In order to get done what
she needed to do, politically.
-Ambassador Sunduk.
-Empress.
Because she's become an empress,
I tried to use bigger patterns.
She's in charge, so...
she has to assert herself,
kind of, sharp lines.
I think he found a loophole.
And a hat.
Favorite costume, hands down,
the baby shower
costume is Peter really wanting
to be the belle of the ball.
And so it's got this
extravagant baby-colored
blues, pinks, yellows.
Feather hat with big feathers
and plumes and a dress.
-Huzzah!
-(cheering)
-Huzz-- ah.
-Beat you to it.
I think, probably
my favorite costume
I've ever worn.
I'm gonna say it. I did it.
It's quite over the top.
You liked what I wore
at the coronation?
You looked stunning.
ELLE: My favorite costume
was the coronation gown.
It looked--
I was like, this looks like...
you know, like, Gucci couture
or something.
Like unreal.
This is like straight off a runway.
PETER: I've actually banned
most of those fabrics.
I thought you were taking
Russia into the future,
-not into grandmother's house.
-Shut up.
All those costumes,
they're just fun to be in,
they're fun to wear.
Let us celebrate.
SHARON:
It just all came together
and it was lovely
and it was fun.
FRANCESCA:
It's a dream job because
it's been an amazing
show to design.
It doesn't matter how I look.
Just what I do.
(laughter)
If you dress well,
no one notices what you do.
Just what you wear.
♪ ♪